[Music]
how'd you turn here to pick up my dress
for the pageant I'm just giving my mom
and I'll go get your dress whose
headbands what they're tiaras but I'm
gonna have on my head when I win this
crayon and they got him that big check
out this station then the what this is
step away from the dresses might be
blinded by all that white walk went into
the dress shop and seeing wedding
dresses is like I want to wear one of
those one day and it's kind of crazy for
me to say that because I've never said
that before
don't you doing a pageant I am but I'm
thinking about this celebration nah I
know you're just teasing you know you
want to like you like this body down and
put a ring on it I mean if you're
insisting on getting married and I feel
we're close enough I can walk in and
give you away I think Gino wants to be
married to me but I think he's scared
because his first marriage failed but I
mean he said that he's a little mudroom
swamp
Lucy look how pretty dresses she's got
on is that moment you I was gonna be
honest people know this before
miss June alright perfect timing
your dress is ready okay cool thank you
great timing we have done great
observations on it I don't would you
like to try it on
no I'm a food fine it's a size 8 yeah I
mean it fit thought I gave a little bit
of wiggle room whenever I got it all
true oh okay
I mean I don't know what this woman's
problem is I mean I was 300 pounds so if
I Sam eight I'm 1/8 I know different
sizes fit differently but I'm 1/8 all
day every day
you ready then thank you thank you I
cannot wait for Gino to see me in this
dress I mean I think I look smoking hot
and it feeds me all in the right spots
so he's not gonna be able to keep his
hands off of me he raisin
[Music]
[Applause]